one of my favorite weird tiny things
that I know is going to resonate with
two percent of this audience when I'm on
a pickup basketball team of random
people when our team gets smoked like
11-3 in the first game the second that
11th Point goes in I get so hyped when
we get smoked where it's very obvious to
everybody that four of the five best
players are on one team and that's why
the score was eleven to one everyone's
natural inkling is to like let's reshoot
for new teams mine is this deep
excitement to get the other four people
together looking at everybody's face and
say guys we're gonna win this game
because we're gonna outwill them even
though they are dramatically more
talented we're gonna out think them and
most importantly we're gonna outwill
them and when that happens Because by
the way 70 it doesn't happen the talent
is just too great and unfortunately we
also found somebody on the other side
who's talented and has will but the
feeling when you know that you are
dramatically inferior and you get a
group together and you out accomplish
them predominantly on will with a mix of
strategy there's something there that
just gets the hairs on the back of my
neck